et puis à deauville toujours hier soir
deux chocs été récompensé il recevait la
cravache d'or c'est à dire qu'ils ont
été les meilleurs dans leur spécialité
en 81 freddy head l'a reçue pour la
quatrième fois pour les courses de plat
pour les courses d'obstacles c'est alain
chollet qui a reçu cette récompense
cela se passait au casino de deauville
en vingt ans de carrière il ça martin a
obtenu 14 cravache d'or c'est un record
difficile à battre mais son fils éric
que nous voyons ici prendra peut-être un
jour le relais hier soir c'était à
lyncher et freddy head qui était
consacré meilleur jockey pour 1981 je
pense que tous les apprentis tous les
gosses qui rend dans cette profession
leur rêve c'est d'être tête de liste est
donc d'être cravache d'or mon grand
souvenir en fait c'est lorsque j'ai
gagné l'arc de triomphe avec bons mots
s'est éteint en 1966 j'avais 19 ans ça
représente combien de victoires
l'année dernière ça représente 123
victoires
elles ont été dures arracher ces
victoires n'ont oui bah c'est à dire que
gt gt à la lutte avec yves saint-martin
le dernier mois nous sommes tenus
toujours un ou deux cours c'était lui
qui était devant moi devant et ça s'est
tenue trois deux ou trois courses
d'avant ça la fin elle a gelé combien de
victoires vous at-il fallu pour obtenir
cette cravache d'or dernier en 1980 on a
obtenu 47 en france et une à l'étranger
mais celles de l'étranger ne doit pas
porter pour l'accrochage alors ça peut
paraître très peu par rapport à freddy
head
comment expliquer que non mais enfin
il ya quelques mois d'arrêt d'un pendant
l'année l'année dernière j'ai dit
arrêtez de moi pendant les deux walis à
course que j'ai eu les côtes cassées
une jambe fracturée ça mais j'aurais pu
emporter la comader et écru un mois
avant la fin de l'année et cette année
j'étais arrêté trois mois là cette année
à cause de quoi
j'ai le genou de fois une entorse du
genou
la pellicule fracture de la piscine j'ai
eu pas mal d'ennuis
il déjà arrivé de remettre une cravache
d'or oui à fred et justement il ya
quatre ou cinq
que vous pensez des cravaches d'or de
cette année fait billet d'alain
chaudière le sida
les cravaches d'or sont toujours remise
à nos mères joker réalité rien dans le
drame trois ou quatre qui ont la
cravache d'or tous les ans ils la
méritent la hauteur d'eau c'est une
solution qui va continuer ah oui
sûrement
vous êtes timide ou même en pour
l'avenir des courses et
et que moi je suis de nature optimiste
donc pour le moment
je continue à espérer je crois que ça va
s'arranger je crois que les gens adorent
les courses excellent telle bonne chose
pour le pays pour l'état même puisque ça
procure de gros revenus à l'état je
crois que l'état va s'en occuper et vont
nous sauver